faire écouter ce fut
comment on dirait sur NRJ qui va tourner
à peu près à peu près partout bonjour
d'accord
[Musique]
tout ce qu'a fait Annie chat c'est très
bien oui mais c'est très noir c'est très
triste
elle va pas faire que que ça toute seule
elle peut on peut pas lui donner un truc
avec un peu de couleur un peu de vie
parce que c'est quand même très chaud ce
qu'elle fait depuis la Star Ac moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est je sais pas c'est
une dépression totale et constante
tu as raison tu as raison vous fusillez
vous fusillez une carrière naissante
d'une jeune femme qui a eu des problèmes
dans son enfance oui elle est comme vous
dites dark un peu sombre dans sa chanson
parce que c'est elle et là vous qui
n’est rien
je trouve ça honteuse de votre part
honteux je sais que vous êtes comme ça
mais à chaque fois ça me scandalise
mais qu'est-ce que je peux répondre
c'est ridicule parce qu'il y a aucune
critique par rapport à ce que j'ai dit
j'ai fait une analogue mais
on dirait de leur mot donc laisse-moi
parler
quelle est la négativité dans ce que la
corde où est la corde c'est pas négatif
ça ouais
c'est ce que j'ai dit elle a une très
belle voix j'espère qu'elle est-ce que
j'ai dit est-ce que j'ai critiqué à
Nisha est-ce que j'ai critiqué ça triste
vie est-ce que j'en ai parlé et oui
n'étant rien et étant comme lui et étant
comme tout le monde
elle au moins elle essaye de chanter de
créer elle elle a quelque chose à dire
mais la vie
mais la moralité de tout ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus rien dire
et on retient qu'une seule phrase
d'accord et est-ce qu'elle est là la
liberté d'expression elle est où la
liberté
Gilles façon je suis pas très inquiet
mais Gilles tu as un bon journaliste
merci est-ce que faire un journaliste il
s'informe il écoute il analyse donc
apparemment tu ne l'as pas fait parce
que tu ne retiens qu'une phrase c'est la
corde écoute ce que j'ai dit je dis que
ce qu'elle faisait très triste et on ne
peut plus dire quelque chose aujourd'hui
soit juger on le voit aujourd'hui
partout dans la presse on reprend un
truc que ce soit pour ici pour les
autres la presse aujourd'hui la raison
il y a que des journalistes il y a très
peu de bons journalistes et il y a
beaucoup de journalistes et vous l'avez
dit ça
arrête de dire des conneries
de la merde
ce qu'il a dit c'est pire c'est toi
voilà je lis et tiens et tu regardes
j'ai un cadeau pour toi
un animal
va mélanger
[Applaudissements]
la moralité la moralité c'est que moi
avec ma chanson de merde j'en ai vendu
984000 je souhaite 900 900 je souhaite à
quel en vendent 5 millions
remettez-la remettez-la moi j'adore la
dictateur
[Applaudissements]
moi je voudrais dire un truc sur
Jean-Pascal j'aurais dire un truc sur
Jean-Pascal et
Jean-Pascal et je le dis Jean-Pascal
Jean-Pascal c'est vraiment mon frère je
le dis vraiment et c'est il a il a moi
j'aime bien les mecs qui ont des
couilles moi aussi géniales
[Applaudissements]
merci Cyril et Jean-Pascal
la semaine dernière il y a eu des
articles des trucs tout ça le seul le
seul qui a twitté de tout les
chroniqueurs de toutes mes équipes le
seul qui a eu le courage de tweeter
contre une séquence et contre des mecs
qui nous critiquaient ces gens Pascal et
c'est vrai que là je me suis dit c'est
quand même j'adore voilà j'ai adoré et
j'ai trouvé que voilà et ce que je
n'étais pas obligé de le faire voilà et
c'est vrai que et tu sais que je m'en
fous totalement moi complètement et je
l'ai fait pas pour la exactement parce
que je le pensais qu'il fallait le faire
et moi j'aime beaucoup aussi et voilà
mais c'est un vrai fou voilà je le dis
et l'agitateur s'il faut le ressortir de
remasteriser je le referai
j'adore oui moi je voulais vous
remercier parce que vous venez de
réaliser un de mes rêves parce que quand
j'étais petite fille j'adorais ce titre
et
faire
et j'étais amoureuse de jean-pascar
mais c'est vrai et sa copine et alors il
y a un de mes copains qui allait à la
piscine à mercredi et en revenant le
jeudi à l'école primaire en CM2 il m'a
dit tiens et alors il m'a donné un petit
papier où il y a marqué pour Delphine si
les gens passeraient et j'étais là
tu vas pas tarder à tenter avec elle